(inspirational music)
- Woo!
- Who am I rooting for this
year at the 95th Oscars?
- It's an easy choice for me.
"Everything Everywhere All at Once".
- Like I said, "She's not most people."
- This film was transcendent.
- It takes the biggest swings,
takes the biggest risks.
(patrons screaming)
It's bonkers, but it
still has a heart to it.
- "The Fabelmans" is my favorite
95th Oscar nominated movie.
- How'd you make it look like
The guns were really firing?
- [Fan] It encapsulates
the movie magic we all feel
when the lights begin to dim
and we go somewhere we have been before.
- The "Best Picture" nominated film
I'm rooting for is "Elvis",
and I might be a little biased.
I left the theater and I felt
like I was on another planet.
- Now is the time.
- I am rooting for "Avatar".
- You saved My Life.
- [Fan] Just seeing it in the theaters
took me to a different dimension.
- The cinematography, the storyline,
the visuals were stunning.
- The "Best Picture" film
that I am rooting for
is "The Banshees of Inisherin".
- It's a film that I
really personally loved.
- The scenery was hauntingly beautiful
and Colin Farrell's
performance was brilliant.
- Stop running away from me
like some fool of a moody schoolchild.
- "Top Gun: Maverick"
should win "Best Picture"
because it really revitalized
the theater experience
that brought everything to the table that
you would think that a "Top Gun" sequel
would bring and then more.
(plane explodes)
- "Women Talking" should get
some Oscar love this year.
- We may need to protect ourselves.
- [Fan] I haven't got nervous
in a movie in a long time.
- Here is why "Triangle of Sadness"
deserves to win "Best
Picture" at the Oscars.
- It's always, "Yes sir, yes ma'am."
- [Fan] Great plot, original
takes, awesome characters.
- This year I'm rooting for
"All Quiet on the Western Front".
- It's one of the most
terrorizing films I've ever seen,
yet one of the most beautiful.
(inspirational music continues)